buongiorno a tutti a tutti anche io sono
molto contenta di essere qui oggi di
poter dare il mio contributo a questo
significativo evento
io nella vita ormai oltre ad avere con
me nella come mission quella di aiutarvi
a dare un volto all'assistente vocale
che magari molte delle vostre case
eccolo qui alexa mi occupo di
comunicazione sono occupata di
comunicazione per molto tempo e oggi vi
parlo quindi di questo di come il
linguaggio ci possa aiutare a promuovere
il cambiamento nel 2018 è stato
celebrato il primo centenario del
riconoscimento del voto ad una parte non
ha tutte delle donne in gran bretagna ed
è indubbio che rispetto magari a questa
foto molto è cambiato per le donne da un
punto di vista sociale politico
culturale economico e anche
professionale anche se c'è sicuramente
del del cammino del lavoro ancora da
fare
c'è un ambito però dove si fa fatica a
vedere il cambiamento succedere almeno
nella stessa profondità e velocità con
cui cambiamenti sono avvenuti negli
altri ambiti
e questo ambito a cui mi riferisco
ovviamente il linguaggio linguaggio è
qualcosa da cui non possiamo prescindere
fa parte di noi è una facoltà che
abbiamo di comunicare di entrare
relazione con altre persone da sempre
perché l'abbiamo appreso nella
primissima infanzia è impossibile
ricordarci il momento in cui abbiamo
detto le prime parole o frasi di senso
compiuto e siamo noi è quello che
facciamo tutti i giorni come persone e
come professionisti professionisti
potremmo quasi dire che il linguaggio in
molti casi è come uno di quei muscoli
del nostro corpo a cui sappiamo che il
cervello da input per funzionare ma qui
non è che facciamo attenzione non è che
ci stiamo lì a pensare infatti succede
così con linguaggio non ci pensiamo
tanto andiamo un po in automatico
andiamo in velocità
se poi pensate alle tante cose che
facciamo contemporanea
mentre la telefonata l'email e
lasciatemi giro eccetera veloce è
automatico
quasi come queste attività che le
abbiamo apprese all'inizio ad un certo
punto non andare in bicicletta andare a
correre ea meno che uno non è maniaco
dico permette agli arti inferiori del
proprio corpo prendi e vai e anzi se già
super i dieci minuti di corsa almeno io
sono anche molto contenta non ci stai lì
a pensare e con il linguaggio spesso ci
succede così a meno che non si è magari
in contesti molto formali in cui devi
fare estrema attenzione a quello che
dice quello che scrivi eccetera andiamo
in automatico e questo può far sì che
inconsapevolmente nella migliore delle
intenzioni non c'è cattiva fede non c'è
cattiveria non parliamo di linguaggio di
odio
parliamo di linguaggio ad uso quotidiano
ci scappano via delle robe ci scappa via
delle cose che veicolano appunto
stereotipi preconcetti e retaggi di un
tempo che è stato e che ci ha insegnato
l'espressione il linguaggio che
utilizziamo e che magari sta cercando di
cambiare nella realtà ma siccome è
inchiodato nel linguaggio e nelle
espressioni che invece continuiamo a
utilizzare in automatico cambia o meno
di quanto potrebbe cioè il linguaggio
quasi fa da freno più che d'aiuto al
cambiamento non facendoci caso e questo
ci succede in tantissimi ambiti su
aspetti religiosi i sospetti di eta di
etnia di orientamento
oggi parliamo di genere perché è di
questo che su cui vogliamo portare
l'attenzione e quindi adesso vi porto
qualche esempio per capire un po più nel
concreto di che cosa stiamo parlando
alla ritendo un termine che in
linguistica ed è finito e piceno cioè
sono quei termini che di base non hanno
genere perché finiscono con la lettera e
e quindi li possiamo intendere in un
modo o in un altro ora prendo la parola
governante allora se la questo e piceno
sostantivo piceno lo faccio precedere da
un sostantivo al maschile
il governante il mio pensiero
probabilmente va verso una persona che
decide
dirige governa un ruolo di potere
se la stessa parola la faccio precedere
dall equivalenze dell'articolo femminile
di cui quindi le picciano prende il
genere la governante
il mio pensiero andrà verso una persona
che si dispone ma lo fa nell'ambito
domestico e familiare probabilmente a
supporto di altre persone
prendo invece un termine che il genere
di swatch e la segretaria segretario
identifica una persona il mio pensiero
la parola fa sempre aprile del pensiero
quindi la parola mi fa pensare ad una
persona che ha probabilmente un ruolo di
assistenza e di supporto ad altre
persone
se io invece questo termine lo intendo
al maschile cambiando semplicemente
l'ultima lettera il mio pensiero
segretario di partito segretari di
sindacato va invece verso una persona
che ha un ruolo di direzione di
decisione stabilisce anche qui quindi
vediamo anche di nuovo tornare un ruolo
di potere
vedete come nella nostra lingua
soprattutto ripidi riferimento a ruoli a
parole che identificano dei ruoli
esiste una certa disparità culturale di
quello che ci viene in mente attraverso
queste parole semplicemente utilizzando
le un altro passaggio che volevo fare
proprio sull'uso del maschile e del
femminile in generale nella nostra
lingua
se io dico le clienti le colleghe le
responsabili è probabile che mi
riferisca alla porzione femminile di
questi tre gruppi
anzi certamente mi riferisco alla
porzione femmina di questi dubbi se io
dico invece i colleghi responsabili gli
addetti mi potrei riferire sia alla
porzione equivalente maschile di questi
tre gruppi che a ciascuno dei gruppi
nella loro totalità
questo perché
perché italiano nella sua evoluzione dal
latino ha perso il genere neutro ed ha
assegnato al maschile una sorta di
doppio ruolo un ruolo di maschile e
quindi al pari nel femminile identifica
la porzione maschile di un gruppo ma
anche quello che viene definito
linguistico linguistica maschile
generico o maschile neutro quindi è il
genere che utilizziamo per appunto
individuare un gruppo io che dovrei dire
voi tutti però evidente no in qualche
modo avendo anche questo appreso dalla
primissima infanzia come proprio
attraverso dei semini sottili quasi
delle polveri sottili come
l'inquinamento nella nostra lingua
c'è una predominanza di maschile perché
è così perché appunto ci hanno insegnato
che per parlare di di tutti usiamo il
maschile e non il femminile che invece
appunto identifica una porzione che in
se per se tu dici abbiamo questa mossa è
fissata su piccole cose ma che cosa ci
cambia cioè noi abbiamo sempre fatto
così ma molte procediamo stata allora ci
sono tantissimi studi di linguistica e
psicologia che dimostrano come
all'interno delle organizzazioni che
sono state oggetto di questi studi la
popolazione femminile che è
ripetutamente per lungo tempo esposta ad
un linguaggio che è in modo predominante
solo un esclusivo fatto di maschile
generico quelli i dipendenti i colleghi
queste espressioni così ha un impatto
misurato sul proprio senso di
appartenenza
l'ingaggio è motivo di partecipazione di
motivazione nel lavoro che fa con
ovviamente alcuna ricaduta sulla propria
produttività all'interno
dell'organizzazione sulla fiducia in se
stesse che queste donne ragazze portano
nel lavoro quella voglia di buttarsi e
di cogliere delle nuove opportunità
magari di spingersi
quindi cominciamo a misurare questo
impatto e se avviene nelle
organizzazioni che sono state oggetto di
questi studi è molto probabile che a
macchia d'olio riguardi più o meno tutte
le organizzazioni e quindi abbia un
impatto sul sistema paese che guarda
caso ha un livello di occupazione
femminile si citava prima inferiore a
quello delle medie di altri paesi non
sarà certo questo l'unico elemento che
lo giustifica e porta a questo numero
però può dare il suo contributo
quindi forse il farci caso
un certo un certo ruolo una certa
valenza ce l'ha volevo fare sempre a
proposito di termine di parole un altro
passaggio se io dico infermiera
niente di strano insomma un termine che
abbiamo sentito utilizzato moltissime
volte così come ragioniera un altro
termine di uso assolutamente comune se
invece dico un'altra parola che fa parte
paradossalmente di questa stessa
famiglia come diciamo classificazione
grammaticale che è ingegnera alla
desinenza che uguale è adesso voglio
fare il sufismo linguistico però ecco
infermiera ingegnera ci pongono dei
problemi io se dico ingegnera su strana
diciamo la verità che le facce diventano
più strane l'impiegata piegata anche
questa è una parola che usiamo tutti e
sono stata impiegata per tantissimi anni
assolutamente chiuso normale
anche qui metto una parola che fa parte
della stessa famiglia e che magari è
meno frequente avvocata a perché
avvocata quindi lo possiamo dire non è
avvocatessa parto
allora sarebbe meglio dire come diciamo
in piedi alta ma che qui stessa famiglia
stesso funzionamento linguistico
avvocata questa la formula corretta
direttrice della scuola chi non ha
incontrato una direttrice della scuola
nella propria vita anche scolastica alla
c'è chi dice che dovremmo dire direttora
comunque facciamo un passo alla volta
agganciamo cia direttrice che già è
quindi direttrice della scuola
nessun problema tutto a posto direttrice
generale direttrice del personale
direttrice di stabilimento e potrei
andare avanti a farvi altri esempi
allora qui a volte sì a volte no un po
mi fa strano un po non mi fa tanto
strano ma si bot amministratrice della
casa
abbiamo detto che tante donne magari
ecco che rinunciano alla loro vita
professionale amministrano le potremmo
definire amministratrice della casa
questo è un problema amministratrice
delegata anche qua drammaticamente nulla
si esclude di usare questa espressione
perché per la casa si e per l'azienda no
alla quando io provo a far presente
questa possibilità denominazione alle
donne che hanno questi ruoli di vertice
di responsabilità la guida delle aziende
il non verbale perché così che mi
ritorna indietro che mi viene restituito
è ma dopo tutta la fatica che ho fatto
per arrivare dove sono e siamo anche
poche mi devo far chiamare con uno
scioglilingua ma allora il fondo ma
perché marcia interrogare su queste cose
se in fondo abbiamo l'abitudine da
sempre al fatto di usare più il maschile
e del femminile perché cercò modo c'è
più veloce e anche se le donne a volte
anno il titolo professionale al maschile
piuttosto che al femminile
vorremmo mica dire che le donne sono più
o meno brave se le chiamiamo con il
maschile o femminile
guardiamo altre cose le qualità ai
risultati le competenze insomma che poi
anche questi termini al femminile se
sono meno valorizzanti di quelli al
maschile ma in fondo perché stare tanto
a questionare queste cose parte magari
la mia naturale passione per i temi
perché perché io ho imparato sempre
dagli studi che esistono che è
importante chiamare le cose con il loro
nome perché per come funzioniamo da un
punto di vista cognitivo i nostri
meccanismi cognitivi un qualcosa non
esiste se non ha un nome e un po come il
file nel computer
se io non ho il nome del file non lo
trovo più allora per come funzioniamo
abbiamo bisogno dei nomi per creare
categorie e magazine aree delle
informazioni altrimenti non riescono tra
in relazione come si chiama cosa mi
passi il coso evidenze che non ho una
relazione significativa nei con
l'oggetto né con la persona e che
relazione posso avere con una donna che
raggiunge una posizione decisionale però
si chiama come un uomo evidente che c'è
qualcosa che stride qualcosa che non
torna
e questo continuare in qualche modo a
non usare il femminile nei modi e nei
contesti in cui sarebbe invece opportuno
farlo continua a nascondere la presenza
di femminile che invece sta rivelando i
ruoli decisionali si sta facendo avanti
e si deve fare avanti e la in prigione
anche joan chiamo invece il femminile
questo uso ancora patriarcale del
linguaggio che ci arriva dai tempi che
furono
ma che può fare la sua evoluzione è
assolutamente alla portata del
linguaggio e il fatto che io sia una
donna non deve far pensare che queste
sono le solite questioni da una tra
donne arte donne che stanno lì che
cercano sempre nodi scalpitare di farsi
avanti a questo non è un discorso che
riguarda solo le donne
parliamo di femminile e guarda alle
donne che riguarda gli uomini riguarda
tutte e tutti perché le donne oggi sono
una piccola minoranza che dobbiamo
andare a proteggere poverine sono il 52
per cento della popolazione sono il 60
per cento di chi consegue in italia una
laurea
lascio stare anche la votazione che in
media più alta e hanno in mano per via
diretta o forte influenza fino all 85
per cento di tutte le decisioni di
acquisto
ma non solo dei prodotti per la casa
dell igiene per la persona cura della
persona cioè parliamo di prodotti di
elettronica di macchine dei prodotti di
risparmio finanziario assicurativo
tradizionalmente associate all'area del
maschile quindi è un enorme bacino di
influenza decisione e di acquisto che
quindi muove un quote di mercato che non
è rappresentato in maniera coerente
corretta nel nostro linguaggio di tutti
i giorni con in più un impatto come
dicevamo prima sul senso di motivazione
partecipazione autostima di questa
popolazione che può fare la differenza
nei numeri nelle organizzazioni e nel
sistema paese invece continuando con il
nostro linguaggio in qualche modo
rimarchiamo il fatto che avere donne
ruoli apicali col titolo maschile è
un'eccezione ad una regola perché
numericamente statisticamente sono
sempre più gli uomini che lo fanno
invece chiamiamo le cose con il loro
nome
e se vogliamo che qualcosa cambi non
dobbiamo aspettare che se ne occupino le
istituzioni la politica
i media eccetera possiamo fare subito
qualcosa
tutte e tutti iniziando a parlare la
lingua dell'inclusione iniziando a farci
più caso a renderci conto delle cose che
diciamo e di che cosa vogliono dire
le parole che utilizziamo i titoli
professionali eccetera eccetera
perché se continuiamo a considerare le
espressioni modi di dire la battuta e
dai che vuoi che sia se guarda questa
come episodi isolati
allora ci potremmo anche dire o non
hanno gran peso ma se invece li
immaginiamo come tasselli di un mosaico
ognuna di quelle espressioni modi di
dire battute ha un peso nella aiutarci a
definire un'immagine complessiva o a
modificarla se vogliamo che cambi e
quindi bisogna lavorare in maniera
certosina sull'espressione di tutti i
giorni su quelle piccole cose di tutti i
giorni del parlare la lingua
dell'inclusione diventando artigiane
artigiani del nostro linguaggio nelle
piccole cose
è così che cambierà come diceva
wittgenstein filosofo del linguaggio
della prima parte del novecento i limiti
del mio linguaggio sono i limiti del mio
mondo inventare nuovi usi talvolta
assurdi delle parole può essere l'unico
modo per allentare le maglie dell'uso
abituale del linguaggio
grazie
[Applauso]